playing private Leonard Lawrence and
Full Metal Jacket
um I'm sure you've been asked everything
my only real question really is
it's so intense those moments and I just
was was any of that improvised was any
of what he was saying improvised he
wasn't even an actor right what's his
name I'm sorry Lee
Army Lee Army who is brilliant in
everything I've seen what would happen
was he he you know he did he was a drill
instructor in real in real life you know
for many years after he you know this
guy did three tours in Vietnam he went
back twice
he volunteered to go back twice
um so he was there you know like for all
the he was in the for many
years over there and you know you know
showed us his
bullet holes and everything and honestly
like the real deal and um
but he has so he had an abundance uh
from being a drill instructor and being
around in that life his whole life in
that world this whole life he had
abundance of things to say but Stanley
so he would he would just say them spurt
them out and Stanley would then type
them all out
word for word but then Lee would have to
then do them every time so he kind of
dug his own grave because he was sort of
at the time just barely an actor and uh
not not to rate his ability because his
ability was amazing but he had just you
know he was green still in my mind he
was green still even as a young man I
was like this guy this guy's green you
know and um but uh and then that was my
first film so like I didn't know any
different but no there was no
improvising but you know so in a way he
was spitting out improvisations but not
when the camera was wrong yeah it's
almost like you know
um because I remember watching the
document Around The Shining and like you
know Stanley's always typing his little
typewriter yeah and you know Jack would
say something you know Little Pigs
Little Pigs and then he'd be like
he's like adding stuff
um